the guy who I killed me was a really
good guy his whole name was Brian
Anderson 37 year old Brian Anderson was
attacked in his home sometime overnight
fresh off a tour in Iraq Inc he went to
visit Anderson his old friend and a
quiet suburban neighborhood outside of
Atlanta he and the suspect got involved
in a verbal altercation over some
property that the victim was storing for
the suspect this escalated into a fight
the too far for nearly an hour before it
came to a bloody finish when the police
arrived on the scene
Anderson was dead with a dozen stab
wounds and Yankee was nowhere to be
found a police officer stopped
Christopher timmreck along Highway 78 he
had a knife and bloodied arms what I
remember doing is I stabbed him two
times if I wasn't in the county jail I
found out that he had a total of 20
wounds on them right 12 of which were
stab wounds six in the front and six in
the back I had no idea I had even done
this right the Iraq war veteran claims
that he blacked out as a result of
post-traumatic stress disorder stemming
from a difficult childhood it was a
defense that did not hold up in court
they found me guilty of felony murder
and malice murder and gave me a life
sentence
and so for the last two-and-a-half years
or so I've been in prison now Yankee is
struggling to accept the idea of himself
as a lifer you see guys walking around
that are 20 34 years into the chain gang
been here their whole life's man and
don't amount to nothing you know what I
mean ain't never even tried to do
anything to take it out of the chain
gang you know what I mean and that's
just not who I want to be despite the
odds stacked against him Yankee is
confident at an upcoming motion for a
new trial but turn things around for him
he has spent months in the law library
looking for loopholes and issues with
his conviction his motion is a long shot
but it could be the only shot he has
I'm looking forward to it but at the
same time like scared to death because I
thought I know if I mess up now it might
not you know be another chance for you
Sammy Haynes knows all about last
chances with a teen parole denials
Haynes knows better than anyone how each
year feels when your sentence might
never end it takes a while but we're
happy grads to hit people
can you play my gang with yourself for
so long and then adventure the truth
gonna get you for me hung there for a
year but in Howard I might never get out
man you failed I'm saying that's the
harder I am doing time knowing that this
might be your life
I do not believe that I'm going to be in
prison for the rest of my life
I believe that I've got
enough in me to be one of those guys you
see walking out of the courthouse you
know on TV on the news after such
mountie years of being in prison he got
let go I mean I want to have wife and
kids and knowing big old house and a
couple of cars and a dog and wrap a
white picket fence around it all someday
know what I mean this that's what I want
you know